hey guys what's up it's 2018 and we got
a new vlog for you and i realize that
vlogs are dead
one of the funniest phone calls i have
ever heard in my entire life
oh my god
happy new year everybody it's 2018. i
know i'm a little bit late it's still
good to see you again it's been so long
what is it like a month since our last
time in eco video i got new year's
resolutions i'm gonna hopefully follow
through on them working on some music
making some cool youtube videos making a
movie this year hopefully we got all
sorts of personal goals around a little
baby boy
that's right it's not just personal
goals we have resolutions for the sam
and eco channel as well if you don't
evolve and you don't work on new things
you don't figure out ways to grow as an
artist you might as well just delete all
your videos and call it a day over
christmas break we had some time off to
think and i realized that vlogs are dead
well i'm being really hyperbolic that's
a word right wow here's what i'm trying
to say there was a lot of stuff last
year that people really didn't like it
kind of all capitalized in logan paul's
trip to japan and taking a lesson from
that it's time for us to do something
new with this channel not a vlog anymore
it's a show a show that teaches you
things shows you things tells you
stories reveals challenges that we have
to deal with emotions we go through as
we try to solve hard problems or easy
problems all the interesting things that
a life in youtube gives you but not the
hold the camera selfie indulge in your
personality and your ego kind of vlog
with this new year comes a challenge we
uh we didn't realize we've we've been
having for the last few years which is
our studio is just filled with junk part
of starting a new year is assessing
where you came from and where you're
gonna go it's 2018 gonna be a great year
but before we get into making a bunch of
videos and making a mess of everything
we gotta go through we gotta clean up
what we left behind from last year
[Music]
here's the thing we've been shooting
videos for years now and a long long
time ago when we didn't have anything we
used to keep everything from every shoot
that we did in the hopes that we might
save some money the next time around if
we ever needed to use that proper
costume or whatever it might be the
problem is studio's starting to fill up
with a lot of stuff as more and more
people have come in to work with us
we've gotten less and less space what do
you do when that happens you gotta purge
[Music]
we have a lot of stuff that's valuable
but it's not doing anyone any good just
sitting here taking up space if we're
not using it we've got to go through
each room individually everything from
props to the workshop to the costumes
make space for what we are using so that
the rest of the year when we want to
make something or fabricate something or
when we need a costume that we know we
have on hand we can just go get it
because this isn't working hey can you
hand me a hanger dude yeah sure
thanks man
but you know who i think is having the
hardest time of all this it's my boy
nico yeah i mean he's been walking
around looking at boxes and stuff and
asking us what we're throwing away and
what we're donating and
telling us hey you know you know you
could still use this and
and you can still use that do we really
need this plaid shirt that i bought for
two dollars at big bear market or not no
the answer is no the answer is no if you
are a frequent viewer of the salmon eco
channel you're probably familiar with
brand integrations we did a whole bunch
of them this past fall google chromebook
this is it let's go real good there use
the app
the shot where a tank runs over a dude
because that's brand season i remember
us talking about sowing your seeds
through the rest of the year and then
the fall is a big harvest well that's
what it looks like thanks for coming on
the journey with us it's what lets us
have carmichael and nick and ren and
gabe and christian and even new people
that income stream we're able to make
videos for you and keep them free to
watch as long as we are up front with
you and very clear about when something
is branded and when it is ad supported i
believe it's actually the best way to go
because you want to watch it you don't
have to hopefully it makes for a better
viewing experience on the channel if
you've been watching our stuff last year
there's some pretty solid ones i
personally was a fan of the walking dead
one what the heck are we doing with
corridor in 2018 i don't know what do
you want to do with it i want to make
more short films making films that no
one else has bothered to make
the idea is so bad that no one would
ever put any money or production quality
behind them but we'll be the ones to do
so yeah we're the first ones to shoot a
short film about farts on a red you know
what i think we should also do we should
we should also hire other people to
start working with us so that our videos
get other creative voices on the
corridor channel other than just you and
me and jake that's not a good idea
that's a cool idea right yeah you know
ren's worked on a couple of videos here
and there too well i know
and wren
years ago having good vfx in a video was
enough to make people take notice now
everyone does it people think it's a vfx
that got us our audience but it wasn't
the vfx it was doing something that no
one else was doing in a space at the
time it was vfx but
bigger than that it was
cinema video games no one else was
making good video game movies and here
we are with a
big old youtube channel because of it so
this year we're going to apply the same
ethos to the corridor channel it's not
about visual effects anymore i mean
obviously we're still going to do visual
effects it's in our blood or elsewhere
that the fire red
but what it's about is once again going
out there and doing those ideas and
making those videos that everyone wants
to see but no one is making because
those still exist no one is really
taking the time to do narratives on
youtube anymore there's a couple people
here and there but so few people are
setting out to do it that there's this
big realm of untapped potential of doing
really cool concepts really cool ideas
telling stories
off of these whatever it doesn't really
matter whether it's a kooky idea a funny
idea crazy intense horror story it
doesn't matter people aren't doing that
and it's time for us to step forward and
do that so that's we're going to be able
to look forward to on corridor in 2018.
more anime themed videos basically
quarter digital is converting to an
anime live action exclusive channel
niko just got a phone call and it's one
of the funniest phone calls i have ever
heard in my entire life remember that
show called snapper hero we did
harley was playing an obsessed fan and
snapper hero and there's a shack out in
the woods and he made a weird montage
like for him like in his obsession with
freddy in the shack
hey i know you can't have snapcom out
here so maybe i can come to you i
recorded all your teleport locations and
i think i know where you live
maybe i can come to you
here's how you wash your hands when
you're in the woods
and this is when you're in the woods and
you get mad
we finished filming we're like i'd be
really funny just to leave this up so we
did it was like three years ago by the
way three years later jimmy and freddie
go there and jimmy goes into the shack
he comes out he's like freddy freddy you
need to see this
and freddie goes in and there's just
pictures of him with like string
connected to him and like obsessed
yeah it was still there three years
later they found it freddy and jimmy
actually found it and they didn't know
they didn't know that it was from the
shoot a craz an insane man's crazy
stalker board of freddie naturally in
the wild that's incredible i ca i can't
believe that i remember that
oh my too
it's incredible i just like i'm so
envious and jealous of their experience
like i i want to be in the middle of the
woods one day and walk into a shack and
see just creepy pictures of myself and i
want my mind blown like they got their
minds alone
yeah right hey guys what's up it's 2018
and we got a new vlog for you i think we
have a chance here to do something
different we're filmmakers we tell
stories find ways to put messages into
our media all in all try to deliver you
guys a video two videos three videos a
week
i would say casey neistat is the first
one to try to evolve the vlog format
yeah but he was really telling a story
and crafting films i think that's a good
goal to strive for it we can do
something special too now that change
might not be instant i think it's gonna
be a huge challenge kind of switching
over this format that we've learned to
do everything from different editing
styles storytelling styles
cinematography styles the whole thing
it's not gonna happen overnight but
you'll be there for the ride actually
we're a hundred thousand subscribers
away from a million we're gonna hit a
million subscribers by
somebody's birthday my birthday and
carmichael's birthday nine year birthday
we'll be nine years old this summer
we're going to give you a new san benico
show and that's what we're going to try
to do in 2018 and carmichael gets to
figure out how to do it all see ya
quarter digital is facing the hardest
challenge we've ever faced in 2018
replacing that light bulb
25 feet nope
how michael gets to do it we're gonna
lift you up blindfolded
oh my god just reach up and i'll
feel for it all right
i'm back